far cry 4 it's a game about majestic
landscapes getting to know the native
population and most important of all
animals lots of weird and wonderful
animals here's a guide to some the
creatures you'll encounter in Far Cry 4
first elephants these are easily the
most powerful weapons in the game just
crawl onto an elephant's back and you
can demolish an entire enemy outpost in
no time
the speed also makes them a surprisingly
effective mode of transportation between
missions but they're not good at however
is playing chicken with a speeding truck
good-night stampy go to sleep
next is the demon fish oh sure they look
you and they make for great fishing too
but be careful when you're swimming
because you never know when they'll
sneak up on you you also never know when
they'll crawl up onto land oh god kill
it kill it kill it dead okay okay calm
down look at that it's a turtle ain't
nothing wrong with some turtles you
should never kill these things in fact
this one looks kind of hungry let's give
it some food ah turtles love raw meat oh
and uh so leopards apparently whoops ah
now here's a majestic creature the Asian
Rhino they may look tough but they're
actually quite peaceful unless you
provoked it in which case you better
have a good escape plan you try no other
animals won't wait to attack you you
might be scouting an enemy outpost one
second and the next you're swarmed by a
pack of bloodthirsty goals which are
basically like foxes if foxes were
complete [ __ ]
oh and let's not forget the wolves
wolves who attack you when you're just
going for a drive in the woods wolves
who won't leave you alone until you pull
you turn and run them right over yes
there are a lot of dangerous creatures
in Far Cry 4 so always make sure you
come prepared
take this bear for example it's huge yes
it's also terrifying sure but it has a
weakness and you know what that is c4
and this pit viper look at it just
blending into the grass so it can bite
you without you even seeing it you know
one way to flush that snake out of the
grass a Molotov cocktail even the nice
gentle animals can turn into real jerks
okay so like this for example maybe I
swerved a truck into this pack of beer
and maybe I took out the sambars entire
family all right fine I'll admit that
I'll admit that fine fine I did that it
would I did it in the in the heat of the
moment whatever but why is it getting so
passive-aggressive on me why is it just
walking right into me
is this deer pulling a Power Move I
don't like it I do not like it one bit
not cool deer not cool what you're just
gonna keep you're just gonna keep doing
this you're just gonna keep walking
right into me okay all right I see how
it is I see how it is all right fine
we'll do this we'll do this you know
what we're done here